legend is one of my favorite typefaces  there are tons of ddos they all have  thick thicks  thin thins  and gorgeous curves but i think my  favorite detail lejeune with 1970s style  razor thin serifs and large x height  looks better than any other  it was originally commissioned by vanity  fair they wanted a new hardworking yet  elegant d  for their challenging editorial needs  there's other ddos that only look  perfect and probably one point size  hairlines can easily disappear at small  sizes or become inelegant and stocky  when big with legends four optical sizes  you can set a beautiful 200 point  headline and every curve is preserved  just as well as 10 point text built for  editorial design it's easy to use on top  of a photo or knocked out on black just  pump it up one optical size it'll all  work out that's why